do you ask me tomorrow to go back to
Helmand I would 100% which is absurd
really considering everything that stuns
me my girlfriend at a time she'd got out
to the shops I bet she'd knit back just
to check on some washing there was me in
the bedroom
fun hang yourself
I was just talked to going to town have
a drink have a fight and get it out of
your system
when you're in you're told it will help
everyone with help April for the oven
and there's one blokes are there there
sadly taking our lives
[Music]
money needs to be spent at the front end
instead of the back it's not getting a
fill word down there too far the top
[Music]
it is five years since Britain's war in
Afghanistan came to an end the lowering
of the flag at Camp Bastion brought to a
close more than a decade of intense
conflict there and in Iraq I was in
combustion on that morning when British
forces left for the last time and five
years seems to gone by in a flash to
think that more than 200,000 British
personnel served in Afghanistan during
that conflict many of which dwell in
fact the vast majority of which had gone
on to live very successful fulfilled
happy lives but some haven't too many to
be frank haven't and I want to try and
understand why that's the case but also
the role in their lives of the military
charities many of which sprung up
directly from that conflict there is no
question that Britain's military
charities do vital work for thousands of
veterans they are simply a lifeline
however Sky News has done some deep
research into how they are funded and it
has thrown up some surprising data
because despite living in a period of
peace donations to military charities
are going up in short they are
collectively getting richer
[Music]
but is the money reaching the parts it
needs to to find out we started in the
seaside town of Weymouth and spoke to
some of the men who live there military
veterans who serve their country that
now battle the state would send them to
fight this is where I keep all of my
military and civilian records with
regards compensation and help and my war
pension it's just reams and reams of
paper that I have to go through in order
to try and get something done every time
I have to open this box it breaks me
that's Pablo Williams's life now stacks
of paperwork kept in the box under the
stairs hundreds of letters each one a
desperate plea for support I've taken
two overdoses purely and simply because
I can't handle going through all this
every five minutes
not what he expected after two tours of
Northern Ireland and service in the Gulf
War Bosnia Afghanistan and Iraq Bosnia
he say he discovered a mass grave mass
graves yes I think in the league of
things it was only a small one there was
about 45 bodies in there one of which
was a five year old girl we managed to
read the report on how she died she'd
been shot in the back of the head the
bullet had exited above her right eye
but she died from asphyxiation
she suffocated basically they basically
buried her life that will never leave me
no no not at all
I can still see the the little dress
that she wore the shoes everything the
memories have left him unable to work
unable to leave the house alone and on
some days simply unable to go on I just
wish I could get back to normal yeah
Pablo might feel like he's alone but
he's not not even in this one town his
bleak story is echoed by everyone we
speak to here they cede the wealthy
charities but can't understand why the
money isn't filtering down I grew up in
Dorset about 20 30 minutes from here and
I member very clearly as a child
the major naval base over at Portland
that's been closed 25 years or so now
but still the area retains strong links
to the military what I have been
surprised by are the number of veterans
living here suffering in secret
suffering out of sight and in that
respect I think Weymouth is a microcosm
for the wider country because they're
receiving help not from big government
not from big charities but from each
other
welcome to the vets hub not a charity as
such but it does get some financial help
from the Royal British Legion and local
businesses this is an example of
something set up by veterans for
veterans because they couldn't find the
help through official channels it's a
part-time project we were quite happy
with that and then you know he passed
forward to 2018 there was four suicides
locally or veteran suicides what if we
had been a full-time project you know
would they have still been here I mean
there's kind of question their families
are asking as well and even though we
know that's just us beating ourselves up
we decided to create a full-time project
the established charities are very very
wealthy and there is no I think is there
not to say that it shouldn't need
someone like you know yourself and be
successful I think the problem why I
personally got with with the hub and
what we've done here
it's even though it's really good to see
it working and you know it's clearly
helped me and a lot of the people coming
through the doors you know the flipside
of that is I don't think we should have
to exist it should never have been a
point in time when you know someone
who's arguably a service user you know
with a very credible and diagnosed
mental health problem bought about by my
service to this country had to turn
around and take matters into his own
hands during the days we spent at the
hardware we heard time and time again
how it had saved lives it is a place to
come and share stories with people who
know what it's like what it is like to
go to war and what it is like to suffer
afterwards for some the hub is the only
reason they can get out of bed in the
morning I was in a Mental Health
Institute
I've been sectioned and I was cutting
myself you know if I'm a neck or cut my
throat there I try to kill myself and
this was going on it was like a big
pattern I've got to get better for a bit
no I'll go back into this but because of
where I am now
you had the veteran sob they sort of
stood behind me for the whole you know
from the bads and and then a good
so why why is it that in this one town
alone we found so many veterans
struggling with life we are told that
the help is there we are told that the
money is there and yet they are largely
fending for themselves and they cannot
be the only ones made homeless five
months ago yeah I mean I've got a bit of
a bad time
couple of weeks ago in Bournemouth
jumped off a cliff yeah we went to North
London in search of the answer and an
evening drop-in session for veterans
this monthly event is a chance for
veterans to speak face-to-face with
different military charities all in the
one room it is also importantly an
opportunity for the charities to talk to
each other something maybe that they
could do better you think there is good
coordination do you don't think there is
just so a wealth of charities all a lot
of money that don't necessarily talk to
each other so at the local level I think
there's really good bilateral
coordination between different veterans
charities but I do agree that on the
national level
there is a lack of overall strategic
coordination in how the veterans
charities operate there are some
wonderful exceptions but as as a rule as
a whole we are not collaborating as well
as we could do many veterans today have
extremely complex problems physical
mental financial clearly no one charity
can fix them all but if they don't work
together the veterans suffer alone
in the 17th century there was no help at
all for injured soldiers the Royal
Hospital Chelsea changed that charles ii
commissioned it Sir Christopher Wren
designed it and the Chelsea pensioners
still live here to this day underneath
us as relevant now as it was 300 years
ago it is an example of veterans care at
its finest and a good place to meet a
man who heads up a charity born out of
the most recent Afghan conflict some
people have got quite a lot of money
others you know like ourselves we're
running on what we raised so it's a
tough area I wanted to ask ed Parker as
the chief executive of a charity about
reserve cash it's sensible financial
practice to have six to twelve months
income in reserve but our data shows
that some charities are sitting on much
much more than that and it's money just
gathering dust I've looked at our
figures and you can see quite clearly
that some charities are sitting on large
pots of reserved cash and I've spoken to
veterans who've said they've tried on
multiple occasions to take their own
life because the help is not there or
they can't find the help and to me that
does appear scandalous yeah it is and if
if an individual reaches out for help
they should get it and if an
organisation is unable to provide it to
that individual there will be another
one that can and it's one should never
just say no and if it does happen it's
it's simply it's a failure
most people who do reach out for help
get it but if we can meet half a dozen
or so veterans in just one town who say
that they aren't receiving the support
that they need then you wonder how many
there are like that across the entire
country after all their stories speak
for themselves